Jeff is with us in Cleveland Ohio hi
Jeff how are you I am doing great Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up
I said truly an honor and a pleasure to
speak with you sir I'm calling for a
little bit of a career advice I've been
listening to you for about eight years
now my best friend Tom had put me on to
you and I've been listening ever since
so first and foremost thanks for all
that you do for people like us both you
know financially and personally I really
really is grateful
well thank you very much how can I help
I'm calling I'm currently in a weird
spot and I'm kind of in-between what I'd
like to do next I'm in a role which I
feel like the environment is is somewhat
toxic and just not good for me
professionally as well as caring over my
personal life as well and I'm looking to
kind of make a move and part of me just
wants to straight up and quit because I
have the financial means thanks to you
and your ministry over the years to kind
of figure out what I'd like to do next
as far as my next career move but I'm
talking to a lot of people when I'm
getting advice you know here and there
and I wanted to get your take on you
know kind of what you would do if you
were me or if I was your son coming to
you for advice on what they would do for
their career make sure you're running to
something from something and you've not
identified the target yet when you say
that part like when you say the target
you don't know what you said you still
haven't figured out where you want what
you want to do well I like my role
currently it's just the environment that
I feel like that doesn't give me an
opportunity to really see Vin Excel in
my current position I than the body of
people you're around sucks or what's the
problem that the quality of people I
feel like it's just not conducive for a
good environment for this so well no no
it's not it's just not a good
environment area is what it sounds like
I mean people aren't you know it's a
bunch of people that are doing all kinds
of stuff except working
I want to put admits just in a
politically correct way on to say on the
air it just doesn't feel like there's an
opportunity for me to really exceed and
I feel like I'm taking all that I could
from this rule now that I have but it's
not the role it's the environment so you
want to stay in the same career field
you just need a new job right well
identify the job and take it and then
quit but you don't have to quit and then
go look for a job there's no reason to
do that you don't think I should quit
and then look for a job no because I'll
be honest Dave I don't really foresee it
being a pleasant environment much longer
for me it's really just taken a toll on
me and in a way that I've never seen in
my entire life before how long have you
worked there over ten years how long do
you think it'll take you to look for a
job and find a job
I ought to say don't know cuz it's not
like I haven't been looking now I have
other means of income that I could
subsidize some of it but it's nowhere
near the amount that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about finding
a job not other means of income how
about what you want to do next go find
what you want to do next where you want
to do it next identify that and land
that that should not take you three or
four six months what do you what field
are you in I'm in the financial services
industry okay well there's tons of
things you can do in that field and tons
of places to bore it it's a long their
communications and writing aspect of
things okay it's still I mean if you
want you you know you're a content
provider in that world there's tons of
that out there that's a that industry
that industry produces more content its
content rich so you know you should be
able to yes go find a job and then leave
but you don't need to you know you're
just having a bad week a bad month
whatever I'm not saying stay there ten
more years but Lord gotta be able to
stay there six months I feel like I've
had that car you could have told you
that six months ago
yeah but you haven't done anything
during the last six months you haven't
gone and gotten the job I have okay you
do what you want to do I wouldn't do
that
I would not quit and walk out the door
until I had something lined up
okay it is unless somebody has got an
ethics problem or there's a sexual
harassment thing going on but all it is
is you work with a bunch of twerps and
you're done with them that's all it is
so you know for the good of your future
and your family I would stay put and
pull the boat up next to the dock and
then then make my move but I'm gonna be
I'm gonna light a fire and go find
something I'm getting out of there I
don't disagree with you leaving you're
saying you have no idea you could be
unemployed for two years where you're
going at this and that is not that's not
advisable not not advisable at all so
hope that helps